some of britain's most high-profile
killers are to have their sentences
reviewed five convicted murderers are
having their cases looked at again among
them are wayne cousins who received a
whole life order for the abduction and
murder of sarah everage
the killers of six-year-old arthur
labino hughes will have the appeals of
their sentences examined as well
as will ian stewart who was convicted of
the murder of his wife in 2010 and his
new fiancee six years later and judges
will consider whether the sentence for
jordan monahan who murdered his partner
and two children was too lenient
iva is at the royal courts of justice
for us hi iva um so is the new justice
secretary behind this
uh it's actually i think the attorney
general suela brevamen this is uh all
part of a wider look at the use of whole
life orders which are the most severe
form of punishment within the uk
criminal justice system they're very
very rare reserve the most serious
crimes and currently according to the
government at the end of last year there
are 61 people serving these whole life
orders but the government wants to
expand their use and that's why
five sentences
of
from killers uh
who are behind some of the most shocking
crimes in recent british history are
having their sentence reviewed at the
same time here at the court of appeal by
five senior judges among them are wayne
cousins uh sarah everard's killer
remember last year he became the first
person to be given one of these whole
life orders for the single murder of an
adult outside of a terrorist attack well
he is appealing his sentence and as i
say his is one of five sentences that
judges will look at but whilst they will
look at whilst they will consider
whether he's been treated too harshly
they're also being asked to consider
whether others have been treated too
leniently including the killers of
six-year-old arthur labino hughes who
were not given life sentences the
attorney general suella bredman thinks
that was too lenient i think it's going
to be grim listening in court going
through these cases today i don't think
we're going to get any judgments today
but we'll keep you posted okay thanks
ivan